>> Laura: THERE WAS ANOTHER
NATIONAL STUDENT WALKOUT
TODAY FROM SCHOOL TO PROTEST
GUN VIOLENCE.
THIS ONE WAS TIMED TO COSIGN
SIDE WITH THE 19TH
ANNIVERSARY HARD TO BELIEVE
WITH THE SHOOTINGS AT
COLUMBINE HIGH SCHOOL IN
COLORADO.
JOINING TO US DISCUSS HOW TO
MAKE SCHOOLS SAFER IS
DARRELL SCOTT.
DARRYL IS THE FATHER OF
RACHEL SCOTT THE FIRST
VICTIM OF THE COLUMBINE HIGH
SCHOOL SHOOTERS IN
LITTLETON, COLORADO.
DARRELL, IT'S SO GREAT TO
TALK TO YOU.
WE HAVE SO MANY FRIENDS IN
COMMON AND I'M SO BOWLED
OVER BY EVERYTHING HAVE YOU
DONE IN THESE 19 YEARS.
I'M SURE TO YOU IT SEEMS
LIKE YESTERDAY.
AND YOU RUN THIS FOUNDATION
CALLED RACHEL'S CHALLENGE.
TELL US HOW YOU THINK IT'S
THE BEST WAY TO PROCEED TO
ACTUALLY STOP THESE SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS.
>> WELL, THANK YOU, LAURA,
IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE WITH
YOU.
I REALLY WANTS TO APPLAUD
YOUNG PEOPLE AS FAR AS
WANTING TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
AND FOR MARCHING FOR WHAT
THEY BELIEVE IN.
I WANT TO JUST GENTLELY
CHALLENGE THEM TO FOCUS ON
MORE THAN JUST FOCUSING ON
GUN CONTROL.
THE SHOOTERS 19 YEARS AGO
SAID IN A CAMERA YOU ARE
GOING TO CHANGE THE GUN LAWS
AND ADD MORE GUN LAWS IT'S
NOT GOING TO STOP PEOPLE
LIKE US FROM DOING WHAT WE
DO.
I'M AS PASSIONATE ABOUT
CHANGE AS THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE.
IN FACT, WHEN THE CAMERAS GO
AWAY, WHEN THE PASSION DIES
DOWN, MY CHALLENGE TO ALL
THE YOUNG PEOPLE IS TO
MAINTAIN THEIR DESIRE TO END
THE VIOLENCE.
AND OUR FAMILY HAS CHOSEN TO
DO THAT OVER THE LAST 19
YEARS.
WE CREATED A PROGRAM FOR
SCHOOLS.
WE REACH ABOUT 1 MILLION TO
2 MILLION STUDENTS EACH
YEAR.
OVER 22 MILLION OVER THE
LAST 19 YEARS.
WE HAVE SEEN SEVEN SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS PREVENTED AND SEEN
AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT THREE
SUICIDES PREVENTED EVERY
WEEK.
FAR MORE SUICIDES THAN THERE
ARE SCHOOL VICTIMS OF SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS.
>> Laura: RIGHT.
>> WE HAVE DONE THAT THROUGH
A MESSAGE OF KINDNESS,
COMPASSION AND HELPING
CONNECT PEOPLE TO ONE
ANOTHER.
BECAUSE, WHEN THERE'S
VIOLENCE OR WHEN THERE IS
REACTION TO THESE KIND OF
SITUATIONS, WE CAN DO ONE OF
THREE THINGS.
WE CAN HATE AND WE CAN
RETALIATE.
DR. KING TOLD US THAT HATE
WILL NOT REMOVE HATE.
ONLY LOVE CAN DO THAT.
SO WE CAN HATE AND
RETALIATE.
WE CAN DEBATE AND
DEMONSTRATE.
OR WE CAN RELATE AND
COMMUNICATE.
AND RELATING AND
COMMUNICATING IS WHAT OUR